I think there has to be leadership  challenge now I think the position is  that labor is voiceless that that that  at a time when the country rightly is  saying we need some degree of leadership  and I think I'd rather have a bloody  difficult woman negotiating for me than  someone who panics over a slightly  unfortunate interview and makes it worse  absolutely I think that he can become  Prime Minister I think metric values are  the values of the Labour Party we I'd  very much like to stand for the you  kicked leadership that's coming up nigel  is still in charge as leader at the  moment but as we know he's all he's  promised to stand down and resign I  ministry taking promised I mean you  think you might renege a good i hope to  say i did see one headline saying and  haven't ruled out a comeback